foreign
[Music]
and welcome to vm's end to end where we
are talking about using virtual machines
Google compute Engine with different
services and tools
um today we are going to be talking
about kubernetes and we are lucky to
have caslin Fields here to join us
welcome caslin hello and thank you for
having me I'm always excited to be on to
talk about kubernetes topics so excited
to get into it today thank you thank you
so much
um and I think you know a lot of people
have heard of kubernetes at this point
but I think it's worth just kind of
um doing a quick intro overview to it
both in case someone hasn't and also to
kind of get your perspectives there's a
lot of different ways to look at
kubernetes so you know what is your view
of kubernetes sure so the way I like to
start out explaining kubernetes is that
it is a tool for running applications at
scale it provides a layer of abstraction
over a number of machines or virtual
machines some unit of compute that
you're actually going to be running your
workloads on but the the nice thing
about the layer of abstraction that it
provides is you can tell kubernetes hey
I want to run this application and it'll
figure out what unit of compute to
actually run that on
within its cluster so that's why we talk
about kubernetes clusters
so another thing that makes kubernetes
so great for scale is that it has a lot
of really nice management tools for
managing these applications as they're
running at scale for example say you
have an application and you want to run
three copies of it you can tell
kubernetes that and you can do it in
such a way that we call declarative so
you declare to kubernetes I want there
to be three copies of this application
running
and if something were to happen to one
of those copies of the application
kubernetes would automatically spin up a
new one so that it's always in the right
declared state that you've told it you
want it to be in so kubernetes has these
nice tools for managing applications at
scale and it provides a nice abstraction
layer to effectively run applications at
scale awesome that that helps a lot and
then
you know I think from my perspective
it's kind of like somebody who's all in
on Virtual machines and and the like you
know I think of them as being really
tightly related because kubernetes you
know it's always running on on a usually
a VM but always on some kind of computer
um is that how you see it from the
kubernetes side like are the are these
related or not
yeah I think that's something that folks
often miss when they're starting to
learn about kubernetes is that it's
really all units of compute usually
virtual machines on the back end but
here with gke Google kubernetes engine
we actually have a couple of different
modes so your perspective as a user on
how kubernetes relates to Virtual
machines will be different depending on
which of those modes you're using so gke
standard mode is the way that we've been
running kubernetes since we've had a
managed kubernetes service for the last
seven years as of August 2022 and so
in standard mode you have virtual
machines back in your kubernetes cluster
and your primary unit of cost for that
GK cluster is those virtual machines
that you've chosen to run as part of the
cluster you select their sizes their
types how many of them all of those
types of things and so that's really
what makes up your cluster
but over the last seven years we've
learned a lot about how companies run
kubernetes clusters
and based on what we've learned we've
created this new mode of operation
called GK autopilot mode which we
released in 2021 and GK autopilot mode
is what we call nodeless kubernetes
in autopilot mode you're using
kubernetes just as you normally would
you use Cube CTL commands you can run
your applications just the same as
normal pretty much but you don't have
access to those virtual machines you're
not choosing the virtual machines that
go into the cluster you're letting the
cluster automatically choose those for
you and your unit of cost is then pods
so in autopilot mode you don't really
see the virtual machines you don't
interact with them so it's less clear
the the relationship but in standard
mode it's a very very close relationship
God yeah I'm I'm much more used to
standard mode actually I I haven't done
much with autopilot so I'm used to
seeing you know when you look in the
compute engine list there's kind of a
whole list of nodes created by
kubernetes
um
but no control plane because that's you
know being handled by the you know by
kubernetes engine um so I guess in this
scenario even those wouldn't show up
um so
I guess in my mind then it seems like
there's kind of three ways you know you
might run kubernetes on
you know compute engine it would be you
know completely up to you you know you
do everything so you run the control
plane and all the nodes yourself or you
use kubernetes engine standard where the
control plane is managed and the nodes
are handled but they're still visible
and then there's the newer autopilot
where everything is kind of taken care
of
um but you mentioned the pricing is
different you know per pod I'm so I'm
used to you know you pay for VMS when
they're on you know regardless of how
much they're used and so there's
optimizations to think about there but
like it's this kind of reservation is
that what we're talking about or is it
something different
yeah so that's exactly what it's like in
GK standard mode you decide which
virtual machines you want to use and you
basically have a reservation on those so
you're paying for those when you have
them
but in autopilot mode I mentioned this
pay-per-pod concept if you're familiar
with serverless models
GK autopilot mode is like a step closer
to serverless though it's still
kubernetes you're still using kubernetes
API any familiarity you have with that
will still apply which is a little bit
different from a serverless model
because there are things you can do
there like running kubernetes Daemon
sets where you run an application on
every single node in the cluster you can
still do that in autopilot mode so
you're not going to see these virtual
machines in your account but if you ran
something like Cube CTL get nodes you'd
be able to see a little bit of
information about the nodes that are
actually running
but like you mentioned the pricing model
is different you're not paying for those
nodes you're not deciding which nodes to
run so it wouldn't make sense for us to
charge you just based on those instead
you're telling us well you're telling
kubernetes what workloads you want to
run so it's really really important to
set your workload resource requests and
limits for your kubernetes workloads in
autopilot mode because that's how we
determine how much compute and how many
how much memory how many resources you
need for that workload and that's what
you're charged based on instead got it
so the the actual kind of CPU and memory
used by those pods to make you know like
a deployment work or things like that is
that the right
exactly yeah it's a like a more granule
granular type model
um
that makes sense and then
I guess my next question you know a
little bit of context first you know I
think a lot of the folks watching this
series are kind of operating you know a
lot you know large sets of VMS or maybe
providing a platform for developers to
work on
um but also you know a fair number of
developers as well
um and like on the VMS you kind of have
to handle everything right and you get
to handle everything but you kind of
have to so there's that you know what
does this look like
um from kubernetes standpoint you know
at this point there's a lot of you have
a lot of experience with it what
patterns are you starting to see with
how the development experience looks
like on kubernetes yeah this is such a
common question from businesses that are
looking to adopt kubernetes how is this
going to change the day-to-day life of
my developers and there are three
primary models that I see companies
adopting when they're adopting
kubernetes in terms of how they affect
their Developers and most large
Enterprises large enough businesses will
have all three of these models somewhere
within them
the smaller organizations might stick to
one or two
but here are the three patterns the
first one is what we call local
traditional development
your developers do their development of
applications locally and then in terms
of how those applications are run they
just throw it over a wall to someone
else
so they focus really on coding and
making applications but they don't
really care about kubernetes or anything
involved with it and it doesn't affect
their day-to-day lives
so the second model
the developers get a little bit closer
they're doing Local app development but
they're also containerizing those
applications
so the way that kubernetes does this
application management at scale is to
have all those applications running in
containers so containers are kind of a
prerequisite for running things in
kubernetes
so in this model your development
lifecycle changes a little bit because
your app developers are still creating
the applications but they're also
deciding how those applications will be
run in containers and then they're
taking those containers with their
applications and throwing those over a
wall for someone else to run maybe
they'll be running on kubernetes but
from there the developers don't really
care
so then the third model is app
developers working directly with
kubernetes
so in this case they're writing code for
applications they're containerizing that
code and they're also thinking about how
that code is going to run on kubernetes
so they're doing things like writing
yaml manifests they need to understand
things like kubernetes deployments so
there's a bit more that they need to
understand about kubernetes in that case
so you can see that there's kind of an
increasing scale of how this affects
developers lives depending on which
pattern you choose absolutely and so
that makes me wonder though if you're
seeing all all three of these patterns
you know how would you recommend people
choose you know like between them like
what should their goal be yeah it's very
much in it depends question
so it kind of makes me think of the the
devops model if you've heard much about
the devops kind of uh
movement I would say the concept behind
devops is really a cultural one
so you've got your developers you've got
your operations and the line in between
them sometimes gets a little blurry as
we saw through these different patterns
so devops is all about who's doing what
in your organization where do those
responsibilities fall in terms of which
role does what
um so depending on how you work that out
in your organization how many people do
you have with the different skills and
how many people do you have kind of in
that middle space might help determine
which of these models you choose and
also if you have a long history of
running a certain type of application in
a certain way you're considering
modernizing it you might go from one to
the other and over time kind of move
towards a role or a model where your
developers are more involved with
kubernetes but you might start with just
a smaller team of folks who understand
kubernetes and do the wall thing so
there's a few different ways it can go
like um I guess like all good things in
software development you know both from
a tech and a human side like it it
depends so okay
um
it depends I think that may be true for
my next question as well and I know I've
got an opinion about this but I'd like
to hear your your take and expertise on
it you know
lots of systems run on straight VMS and
now a lot of things run in kubernetes
how would you recommend people choose
whether or not to use kubernetes
yeah there's a lot of different kind of
facets you can come at this question
from and I feel like it's a question
that
folks ask a lot and often don't get
really clear answers to him because I
think there's so many different
perspectives to look at it from but I'll
start with one that's
close to to my heart because I've been
dealing with it lately so recently I was
spinning up a game server
um just for me and my friends to play a
game together and a really common Trend
in Game servers these days is to run
them in containers it's really nice way
to package the game Surfer because it
can include all the stuff that the game
server needs all in one convenient
package and kind of how to spin that up
becomes a little bit easier
so I've already got a container for this
game server me being a kubernetes expert
you might think I would definitely run
that in kubernetes
but we're not talking about a problem of
scale here this is just one server for
me and my friends to use to play a game
together I don't need all of the
additional management capabilities and
abstractions that kubernetes provides so
I'm going to run that on a virtual
machine so that kubernetes being a tool
for scale is a really important thing to
consider when you're considering
kubernetes versus compute like virtual
machines yeah that makes a lot of sense
and we have a
I I think you're probably aware of this
but just in case folks don't know we we
have a
um a way to run just a single container
on a VM so straight from from the cloud
console if you go and you just give it a
URL or an image it'll start it up
um so yeah I've definitely seen that and
I guess the other
big scenarios that I've I've seen where
people are kind of deciding maybe
deciding to use the VM instead is
um you know where you've got a lot of
existing applications that are not in
Cloud you know maybe so they're on
Windows and that sort of thing
um things that chat with the registry a
lot are not super compatible with
containerization and and maybe you know
other state that kind of thing
um so I've seen that show up and then I
guess the other one might be kind of
large databases where you've got a you
know pretty significant database that
um you already know it's going to be you
know up and high traffic and you want to
treat it kind of different than the rest
of the system a lot of people seem to
put that in a VM even if the rest of the
software is in kubernetes yeah I
mentioned that containers are at the
core of how kubernetes does what it does
and the whole model of containerizing
applications often we think about
microservices that doesn't necessarily
have to be microservices but running
things really effectively in containers
requires a different Viewpoint than the
way that we've been developing
applications so a lot of these more
traditionally developed applications
will be kind of weird once you start
trying to move them into containers I
think databases are a great
like example because it's totally
possible to run a database in kubernetes
but it requires you to separate your
thinking about the database as an
application and the data that you store
in the database so that's a really weird
way to think about it for a lot of folks
who've been doing that kind of work for
a long time so
might consider other Solutions
if that's the if that's the thing that
makes sense
um thank you so much this was like a
really great overview of the the space
and kind of thinking around it I I hope
folks are you know ready you know
whichever direction you're coming from
either add some VMS to your kubernetes
or you know add some kubernetes skill to
your your kind of VM expertise if if
folks are in that mode kind of want to
give things a try what would you
recommend there's so many different ways
to learn these days so a few different
ways for one of course there's the
Google Cloud Tech Channel on YouTube I
also run a series called GK Essentials
on our YouTube channel so if you're ever
looking for gking kubernetes information
we've got a variety of videos out there
I know that we do
um we also have if you like live webinar
type learning
um or maybe you can ask live questions
while you're learning something or
something like that we have our Cloud on
air uh webinar series and I know I've
done several of those on kubernetes we
have
um chicane related topics on pretty
regularly and I'm sure that we have ones
ones about various compute options and
things like that as well so definitely
check out the cloud on-air webinar
series and if you want to get Hands-On
we have things like our quick Labs
um
solution for for getting Hands-On with
tutorials guided tutorials that teach
you how to do things
and if you want to get Hands-On in a
less structured way if you just want to
play with kubernetes there's a couple
things I'd recommend for One Mini Cube
so mini cube is an open source tool
that's associated with the kubernetes
open source project and it's for running
a kubernetes cluster locally just a
small cluster that you can play around
on to get a sense for how kubernetes
works
and then
if you want to learn about how to run
things on kubernetes and not about
kubernetes itself so running kubernetes
from scratch
you might think is a great way to to
start learning things and it is if you
want to learn about how to run
kubernetes itself and how kubernetes
itself is built but if you want to learn
how to run things on kubernetes you
might want to skip that part and use a
managed service like gke where the
kubernetes part is provided for you and
you can just worry about running things
on it and figuring out how that side of
kubernetes works yeah I absolutely agree
with that and thank you very much that's
a very extensive list of things to try
we will get the links to those things
down below thank you so much for coming
on
thanks so much for having me it's always
a pleasure to talk about kubernetes and
especially how it relates to compute
like I said I think that's something
that people often miss when they're
learning about kubernetes so I'm really
glad we got to talk about that today
absolutely and all of you folks who are
like becoming or already are experts in
compute engine everything you know about
that applies to you know these nodes
that are running kubernetes so
um go please give this stuff a try and
um thank you thank you thank you for
watching this far and we will see you
next time
[Music]